so why how do you know it's going to
work in three years time why the three
years because it sounds like you've got
it all figured out now that you know
what a great guy he is and if you both
need to work on it sounds like a backup
plan yeah because like the three years I
don't think I don't think it's I don't
think he's an amazing guy I think with
time he will also it I feel like we need
time to figure ourselves out and when I
say that I mean I feel like he's not
ready to I feel like man a man's under a
lot of pressure he feels like he has to
have X amount of money he needs to make
sure he can keep a woman because I feel
like men feel like women will cheat on
them if they're not doing certain things
and I think he feels like if he doesn't
provide me with a million roses and all
of that I'm not going to stay loyal to
him he doesn't realize that I'm a
religious person that's not going to be
a problem if that makes sense I just
think that you need to get it sooner or
later another conversation because you
can both work it out together and grow
together well but in three years time
you could you you can both be in
separate places in three years yeah you
might as well do it together you know
what you want you sound like you know
what you want you sound quite sensible
and reasonable so why not do it now and
see where you both are in three years
rather than wait for years as to jump in
because there's a lot that can happen in
for you well you can get there together
you know he's not there yet you know
what he needs and you can be there to
support him and I think that's such I'm
so sorry I think there's certain things
that you need to work I get where you're
coming from I think this because you
guys got married when you were younger I
think there's certain things where you
have to work on by yourself to then be
able to come together with someone so I
get the three years thing because
clearly you've got stuff that you want
to work on and growing whatever and he's
got his own issues and I think if you
guys get back you guys get back together
that precious we're going to be there
because you haven't worked on your
individual selves that's why I always
say even with marriages and because I
decide to get married and stuff but I
know that I'm not ready to get married
now because the stuff that I need to
figure out and these are things I need
to figure out by myself before I can
then come together to figure out that to
figure that that part of my life out to
get me yeah okay I still think you
should want to go Carnival that's right
I want to hear that you're figuring
yourself out they just think you're
sleeping yeah in the streets and
honestly that's what it sounds like
because I don't understand what do you
know it's not that can I ask you can I
ask you how how long it's been since you
both separated like how long have you
been figuring it out
um I'll say it was the start of the
pandemic but it's not that we're
figuring it out I think it was just that
we were two different people coming
together and the pressures of the
pandemic obviously put a lot more strain
on us and I feel like also this concept
like for example
we people believe that if you're married
you have to sleep in the same bed every
single night whereas some people's
relationships aren't like that I didn't
understand that when I was younger that
actually some people genuinely don't
want to be in a bed with someone else
every single night and that's something
that I'm only coming to terms with now
if that makes sense so I think more the
more that I'm growing as a person I'm
learning a lot about myself and I'm
accepting as well that you don't have to
have what social media show as a as a
traditional marriage you can have your
own version yeah can I ask you a
question though do you think you and
your partner have the same core values
yes and I think that's the only reason
why we're I can see me being compatible
with him because so what's like the real
like I don't understand what what's not
there then it seems like he's a great
guy yeah no I think I think no no I
think it's not that he's a great guy
it's I've made a choice and I feel like
I will do whatever I can to make sure it
works okay if that makes sense because I
think especially with marriage it's a
big commitment and you know you do it
through thick and thin yeah um I think
it's more
um I didn't understand like when he did
mention if he did mention multiple
partners or having other partners for me
that was like what do you mean but I
then had to like recheck myself and
actually say that's not something I'm
not used to or I'm abnormal or that
isn't the norm
um so I think when I initially reacted
and again that was the trauma from the
first relationship coming through that I
had to unlearn it was almost like oh
that means you must be cheating every
day when actually he wasn't so it made
us very toxic for no reason so it kind
of goes back to like women can't handle
the truth well I've separated and like
revisiting what I actually want in life
and how it impacts me I've realized that
actually it's not I can't handle the to
mature if that makes sense then I
wouldn't be able to but as I've now
learned a lot more about myself I'm like
yeah have you had help for your trauma I
guess it was more professional help yeah
well I've done I've done counseling it's
not uh I would yeah I've done counseling
and stuff I don't think I think it's
just time so sometimes you don't even
count doesn't help it's just just
maturity I think it's more reason about
emotional management yeah in your
emotions
um in line with what's going on because
often we we have emotional responses to
things that are happening at that time
yeah we've thought about them we've
we've and I'm and I know someone's gonna
say oh you're mad you're saying we're no
we think about things that could happen
we think about those things think about
it and then when we're confronted with
the situation that had we respond to the
because of your background I think
you're quite sensible in it but what I
would say is that for most women the way
you're handling it wouldn't be good
advice because for most women taking
time away and pushing it to the Future
just means racking up bodies racking up
more trauma and expecting a guy to come
and take hold of it in the in in the
future and I think that's where like
obviously like my faith comes in if that
makes sense because obviously that's
what will keep me in check in that sense
because I I don't believe in sort of
committing fornication like that to me
it protects me a bit more from that
um obviously women who might not share
my same background might be a bit yeah
maybe they might you know because yeah
them hidden is is taking more Willy yeah
but but are you actually this is the
question I would ask is are you actually
dealing with the issues at hand because
so so you're working on them separately
but you're not working on them together
and that issue so when you come back
you're going to be a different woman and
he's going to be a different man and
then there's going to be other issues
because you're not working together so I
think what's happening is I'm growing
into who I am and he's growing into who
he is and if it matches this is why I
say I give it time because if it is that
we work out we work out if not we're
just getting better at just say like
because I've got a five-year-old we're
getting better at co-parenting yeah I
mean so we've got it we're we're getting
better in our relationships what's the
separation his choice or yours
it was
I guess are both come on someone someone
started the conversation it wasn't who
started this way it wasn't a nice
separation yeah it was very it was a
very
um abrupt and sort of not great yeah but
who who started the cut like someone
it's dishonest to say that it was a
mutual thing
like someone has to start the
conversation
um someone else to say this isn't moving
out or I'm moving out or we're
this isn't working let's take some time
I guess the guy would he would say it
more than I would but then it's
it's more because I would uh yeah I
guess he would say it so you see it as I
can't take argument so yeah so it's his
choice yeah okay yeah that's abnormal
usually it's like the other way around
yeah no no I guess it was his choice but
it's more I think um obviously where we
had a child involved it was a lot harder
um because we couldn't get the right
grieving or time apart that we would
have had to because it's almost like we
had an argument the day before and then
because of my daughter we'll have to now
stay in communication
um I think the time the covert time
really helped sort of put that aside do
you think like if you called him
tomorrow and said like I want to work
this out let's move back in together he
would do it not yet not yet I think and
he's also agreed in a few years
potentially it's more likely whereas I
think he isn't where he wants to be and
he knows that I'm not where I want to be
and I think one of the biggest things
because when we did break up I never had
a hot girl summer let's say like I've
never experienced that I came from a
culture where we didn't really go about
the house I'm not trying to be rude yeah
but didn't you just say you were at
carnival before
so I never really experienced and I've
experienced that sort of date in or
casual dating or even like you know so
when I first came out of the Pan um the
relationship I was like okay yeah let me
explore this I tried online yeah I tried
online dating it was horrendous I tried
you know
meeting people in my life it was it was
a joke so yeah like I now get to go
Carnival as a single person I guess with
my friends but again it's not it's just
for fun for me it's nothing like nothing
there's no guys
it's not serious for you but if you're
looking at it from a male perspective
these are all the flags that say okay
she doesn't want to do this no but it's
not I don't go Carnival too
it's inevitable like even if you try not
to you could be standing a guy once yeah
yeah
a standby is inevitable because it's you
know when you're in a relationship and
there's things that is you know you're
me well okay let me put it like this as
from a male specific perspective and I'm
not a male but look at it like this
you're making yourself available for men
to approach and it's kind of like your
words really aren't matching what you're
saying because like you said you're a
traditional woman traditional women
don't go to Carnival no this is what I'm
saying I'm saying like let me let me
finish like my mom my grandma wouldn't
be caught dead at carnival they said
they want Vibes they're like what are
you talking about yeah
it's on insult it's just like you can't
beat I think people are mistaken what
Carnival's about because obviously
Carnival yeah it's a Vibe it's more food
maybe maybe at one point but I'm sorry
you cannot convince me that it's
completely cultural when there's girls
with their asses twerking I'm sorry
there's people having sex on the street
you cannot convince that this is but I
think what the I think what initially
Carnival was wasn't this like even this
dagger dagger dagger like so that's a
part of their culture let's say I it's
not me that's going to be gay
I've done Carnival I've taken part and
all I've had costumes in England and in
Barbados and the safest place if you
want to go as a woman and it's to be
inside the band yeah where you're safe
not to be out in the crowd not to be out
in the crowd and I don't understand when
people go and they say oh if you want to
go on experience Carnival go on Sunday
children's day yeah yeah let's just go
on a Sunday but no decent one was gonna
go on a Monday as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible